(suspenseful music)
(water gurgling)
- [Narrator] During the Cretaceous period,
Mosasaurs were among
the oceans most fearsome
and successful predators.
Mosasaurs were marine reptiles
that are thought to be
closely related to snakes
and monitor lizards.
They were highly adaptable
and many different species evolved
and came to dominate
ocean habitats worldwide.
Some even took to fresh
water rivers to hunt.
Many prowled the open ocean,
devouring fish, sharks,
plesiosaurs, sea turtles, sea birds,
and sometimes even smaller mosasaurs.
Mosasaur size varied greatly.
Two of the largest mosasaurs
were Mosasaurus and Tylosaurus.
Each stretched 30 to 50
feet, longer than a T-Rex.
Meanwhile, many smaller mosasaurs
were no larger than a dolphin.
Yet most species, no
matter how large or small,
could be characterized
by a long serpentine body
with a powerful tail which
they moved side to side
as they slithered through the water.
They had paddles that were
likely used for stability
and large heads that had
powerful, flexible jaws.
Their jaws contained two
rows of conical teeth,
designed to chomp and hold prey
before swallowing it whole.
The top marine reptiles since the Triassic
had been ichthyosaurs and plesiosaurs,
but they were in decline
when mosasaurs came onto the
scene during the Cretaceous,
leaving room for a new apex predator.
According to theory, mosasaurs evolved
from terrestrial lizards
that adapted to the oceans
by the middle of the Cretaceous.
Then, during the 20 to 30 million years
leading up to the
extinction of the dinosaurs,
mosasaurs rapidly adapted to
ocean habitats the world over.
We know this because
fossils have been found
on every continent, including Antarctica.
When dinosaurs became extinct
some 65 and a half million years ago,
mosasaurs vanished from
the fossil record as well.
While it's not known
whether they died off
instantly or gradually,
one thing is for certain:
the ocean has never again
seen marine reptiles
as massive and as great as mosasaurs.
(gentle cinematic music)